esta vez nos dicen tibias se siente en
una rueda de la fortuna en el tiempo de
igual a cero la siguiente gráfica
muestra su altura h en metros t segundos
después de que la rueda empezó a girar
así que si vemos esta gráfica de aquí y
nos fijamos aquí en el tiempo te iguala
0 ella está a una altura de bueno veamos
aquí tenemos un metro y medio entonces
aquí sería bueno casi dos metros cercano
a los dos metros y después empieza a
subir su altura empieza a subir su
altura hasta que llegue al punto máximo
en el punto máximo está cerca de bueno
34 metros y después de este punto máximo
la altura a la que la subieron en la
rueda de la fortuna empieza a descender
hasta llegar de nuevo a dos metros y
medio y después empieza a volver a subir
hasta que llega de nuevo a su altura
máxima de 34 metros desde el suelo muy
bien vamos a ver que nos preguntan y la
pregunta es la siguiente aproximadamente
el tiempo tarda libia en dar una vuelta
completa en la rueda y bueno nos
preguntan en segundos así que veamos
esta pregunta me parece bastante
interesante pero vamos a resolverla
observa lo siguiente aquí empezamos en
el punto más bajo que tenemos y después
empezamos a subir hasta el punto más
alto y de nuevo volvemos a bajar al
punto donde empezamos y justo aquí
tenemos de nuevo el punto donde
empezamos es decir dimos una vuelta
completa y justo aquí tenemos un tiempo
de 60 segundos porque el tiempo está
dado en segundos y si observas después
de esto volvemos a subir y volvemos a
bajar también en otro periodo de 60
segundos por lo tanto puedo decir que
aproximadamente el tiempo que tarda
tibia en dar una vuelta completa en la
rueda bueno es de 60 segundos 60
segundos así que ya con esta respuesta
podemos ver si estamos bien de lujo
estamos bien
vamos a hacer un ejercicio más bien
hagamos este de aquí y dice un doctor
observa la actividad eléctrica en el
corazón de finn durante un cierto tiempo
la actividad eléctrica de fin es cíclica
muy bien como esperamos que sea y llega
a su máximo cada 0.9 segundos si te
representa el tiempo en segundos y
representa la actividad eléctrica en el
corazón del fin en voltios cuál de las
siguientes gráficas puede modelar esta
situación bien veamos en este inciso a
qué es lo que está pasando aquí si
observas tenemos que cada bueno observa
cada ciclo es más grande que un segundo
porque aquí tenemos un segundo y es un
poquito después de un segundo
entonces supongamos que es 1.1 segundos
aquí tendría 1.1 aquí 2.2 3.3 ya lo que
voy es que esto es más grande que un
segundo por lo tanto no puede ser cada
0.9 segundos
así que por esta razón puedo descartar
el inciso a vamos a pensar en el inciso
b si observas el inciso b bueno pues
esta si es menor que un segundo si
tenemos un ciclo menor que un segundo
pero el problema es que es mucho menor
que un segundo es casi tres cuartos como
0.75 segundos por lo tanto se repite
cada 0.75 segundos cuando sea cuatro
quintos o algo así pero no es nueve
decimos 0.9 segundos debe estar más
pegado a 1 así que veamos las siguientes
opciones tengo estas dos el inciso c
bueno este sí parece que es cada 0.9
segundos si observas se cumple un ciclo
cuando estamos en 0.9 segundos así que
estoy casi seguro que esta será la
respuesta correcta pero vamos a
verificar y revisar también el inciso de
y si observas el inciso de está justo a
la mitad es cada 0.5 segundos por lo
tanto ya podemos estar muy seguros de
que él
es la mejor representación del enunciado
del problema que me decían acá arriba y
es más tú puedes verificarlo puedes
pensar que 0.9 segundos por 4 es 3.6
segundos así que en 3.6 segundos debemos
de dar cuatro ciclos y aquí está observa
uno dos tres cuatro ciclos si observas
por ejemplo este tenemos uno dos tres
cuatro ciclos en algo que es antes de
tres segundos y bueno así puedes
verificar para cada una de estas tomarte
un cierto número de ciclos y ver si eso
concuerda con tu gráfica pero bueno ya
tenemos lo que parece ser la respuesta
correcta así que voy a subir mi pantalla
y vamos a comprobar la respuesta